digamos que necesitamos encontrar una
solución para la ecuación diferencial de
la derivada de con respecto a x que es
igual a x al cuadrado entre a la ye
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta les daría una pista
es una ecuación diferencial separable
resolvamos estos juntos cuando
trabajamos con cualquier ecuación
diferencial lo primero que debemos hacer
es ver si la ecuación es separable y
cuando digo separable me refiero a que
puedo separar todos los términos que
tienen que ver con ye y dejarlos del
mismo lado donde está de g también puedo
separar todos los términos que tienen
que ver con x y tienen que estar del
mismo lado
dónde está mi diferencial de x como
podemos hacer esto si multiplicamos
ambos lados por el ala y se le cancelará
la aie de este denominador luego podemos
multiplicar ambos lados por de x si lo
hacemos permítanme mover un poco esto
para tener más espacio podemos cancelar
esta de x de la izquierda y nos queda
esta de x
al lado de la equis cuadrada todo esto
nos queda como el ala y bordes igual a x
al cuadrado por de x el simple hecho de
que podamos hacer esto nos muestra que
son separables ahora lo que podemos
hacer es integrar ambos lados de la
ecuación vamos a hacer lo cual es la
integral de alaye por d lo genial de la
expresión de elevado a algo en este caso
es que la anti derivada de esto siempre
es igual a sí misma y ya lo hemos visto
en otros vídeos y siempre expresó mi
admiración al respecto
esto nos queda como a la de la misma
forma si queremos la derivada de alaye
con respecto a y nos va a quedar lo
siguiente
recuerden que esto funciona porque
estamos integrando a la y con respecto a
la integral de alaye con respecto a y es
que a la y esto va a ser igual a la anti
derivada de x al cuadrado con respecto a
x incrementamos el exponente y nos que
x al cubo ahora dividimos entre el
exponente incrementado dividimos entre 3
y ya que tenemos integrales indefinidas
debemos poner una constante en al menos
uno de los lados de la ecuación más ce y
para terminar ya que en muchos exámenes
piden que el resultado quede como una
función explícita de y vamos a aplicar
el logaritmo natural en ambos lados de
la igualdad a qué exponente tenemos que
elevar y para tener el iedt justo por
esto aplicamos el logaritmo natural esto
se simplifica allí y esto es igual al
logaritmo natural de x al cubo entre 3 +
c y con esto terminamos